in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast in our new
podcasts office we are moving on the
[ __ ] oh yeah man so I've been uh I think
Muriel got a little tired of me bringing
strangers into the house it makes sense
yeah I mean yeah not only that you know
like y'all can't get any private time so
I totally understand man but I actually
like the fact that we have an office now
because it feels professional it feels
professional but I still dressed it up
like a living room hey you're on bran
dude don't make the same mistake we did
we [ __ ] went hardcore we spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars
building that [ __ ] JK new set right
only to find out eighty percent of our
fans absolutely hated it but low-key
though I [ __ ] hated it too okay so
for people who don't have have never
watched JK news which if you guys don't
know what that is so so there are some
people who have been watching that
finding out of fighting about this
podcast without knowing who we are okay
Joe and I are youtubers originally
that's what we started at and so there
was his channel called JK news they're
still going on today
that's [ __ ] really dope and data was
a big part of that you know we was just
basically we get together we talk in a
circle and we talk about the news that's
all it is exactly and so you know when
the channel started doing really well
you know I think for our personal dreams
we're like okay let's [ __ ] step this
game up and you know Barton Joe wanted
to take it to the next level which was
like [ __ ] lobs lights cameras action
doing all the [ __ ] because his channel
was doing so well
we released one episode and everybody
thought is suck dick it was so much
money was pretty bad like I didn't
realize how much people hated it they
were like can we [ __ ] hate this setup
it's so weird and I I mean it's it's
very distant - yeah and it feels cold
like a new set like it took all the
elements of what made JK news great like
the closeness and the depth and then the
the the YouTube real raw fuel yeah and
it took it into a corporate space
and it made it seem so stale and I was
like [ __ ] we [ __ ] up because I think
that was our first lesson and not being
able to understand our fan base and
looking back I think it's like a
everyone goes to this stage right of
business development like there's a
stage where you kind of satisfy your ego
yeah and you're like we're coming up now
so like we need to be fancy now you do a
lot of things but in reality like all we
had to do is probably make the set look
a little bit better you know like
there's probably just a few tweaks we
needed to do but people came for the
channel for the realness of it yeah and
what we did is we took that realness out
yeah yeah but that was a hard lesson
learned and and you know I just take it
as a as a loss and go but that's the one
thing about I guess business ownership
is you have to kind of like realize the
losses and can you stomach the pain
because it doesn't just always go up
yeah yeah I mean that's that's the the
good life lesson for us anyways and for
you guys too was just yeah we I it was
that satisfying ego part that was really
hard um even for me like on the channel
I stopped doing these you know channel
vlogs and stuff at a certain point
because I know I should be doing
something better but the reason why
people were coming onto this channel was
because people wanted to see that yeah
they like that person ability they'd
like that they'll those videos now I
don't do it as much now not because I
don't want to do it I started trying
doing it again it's just now we're
taking that content and putting it the
podcast stuff which which for me is
better because instead of having sound
bites I could take it thoroughly explain
myself yeah I think like where you do
best is when you're able to like really
marinate on a topic and talk about it
without a time restraint yeah because a
lot of things get taken out of context
and you can't really explain yourself
fully so that's what probably happened a
lot on JK news is like we only got like
12 minutes and there's six people
fighting for attention yeah
and sometimes we don't do a good job you
know explaining everything and then
there's backlash or whatever but with a
podcast we got as much time as we want
exactly so we have a thought and we
could thoroughly explain the process of
how we
to our conclusion and if somebody has a
different thought process behind it
which still [ __ ] happens now where
people don't listen to the full podcast
and they only hear hard a bit and they
get upset so I had Chris so song here
right and it's funny too because he it
was a really great podcast he just came
out recently where he was talking about
his his chien so Chris cheated on his
girlfriend twice oh [ __ ] and she stuck
around and she's trying to help better
me figure out why he's doing this
wow what a good woman yeah oh yeah and
you know and I think a lot of people
have you know in the comments they're
like oh he doesn't deserve her they're
gonna break up either way they don't
know what a healthy relationship is and
and what I'm finding out too is that
when when they listen to the podcast
sometimes people get heated up because
they've been through those personal
experience and they write the comment
before they actually get to hear the
whole podcast yeah they're like talking
as if while they're listening so it's
like well he doesn't he's not taking
responsibility he is taking respond if
you listen to the whole podcast he's
taking responsibility and he's very
grateful to have somebody who will stick
around with him even though he's broken
and so like I read this comment which
was kind of entertaining in the sense of
how naive this person was they were like
this is why you don't this is why you
don't get together people who aren't
complete projects it's like whoa people
are complete projects that's how you
view things like you find a perfect
person exactly it's like I don't every
person is a broken piece of [ __ ] back
like what are you talking about have you
lived life
I name me one person who doesn't have
trauma baggage issues mm-hmm everybody
got something yeah they're a [ __ ]
idiot yeah when I [ __ ] read that I
was like it's funny because you're
saying good luck to them in a sarcastic
way as in oh good luck finding anybody
to be with somebody like you and I'm
like good luck you finding somebody to
be with somebody has to be with you a
human being who judges somebody based on
them being a perfect person which
doesn't exist it doesn't good luck to
whoever you're with that's probably just
an in so that's never been in a
relationship a thousand percent they
have this false [ __ ] imagery of what a
person is and it's like even the call
purse somebody a perfect project it's
like is that how you view people that
you're with it's a very weird thing to
say it's like you're gonna find out too
when you get with somebody you have this
image of what you
think perfection is and then when you
fall in love you find out that your
vision of perfection was wrong and that
person is going to instill life lessons
in you just like you will for them and
that's that's the funny thing it's like
everybody has this weird thought of what
they think that they want but you don't
know until you're in the thick of it
because I am I me growing up true even
some of my friends like you I would have
never thought that you would end up with
a girl like Mary oh oh
timon I dated yeah you know so it was
like yeah I would have never thought to
yeah I would ever never thought it would
have been this this Korean girl that's
you know she's very goofy and stuff but
you know she's like loves Disney's she's
very innocent that's not the woman that
people usually saw me with but I never
knew what I wanted until it was
presented to me and I didn't have this
concept of her having to be a perfect
human being we just kind of grew
together and we figured it out as we
went yeah that's true and I think it's a
part of maturity too because you know
like when the early stages you're like
oh man that girl premium and you're just
looking at her looks yeah like when I
mean guys are [ __ ] idiots do like
we'll be like she's so fine and then you
value women from their looks you could
do better homie it's like what are you
talking about better like she might be
hot as hell but she might be really
[ __ ] up in the head I don't know oh is
that better really yeah yeah I don't
know I mean if you're just thinking
about sex maybe but then there's so many
to it right but then in the very
beginning stages you like I want some
perfect great a [ __ ] at least the guys
I was around they're like straight
brutes I think most guys were like that
yeah and then later on you go oh my god
like you know relationships you want
someone to balance you out you want
someone who's a life partner and most
guys I think they're just literally
thinking from their dicks yeah as much
as guys say no I don't I'm nice I want
romance you're still thinking from your
[ __ ] dick because there's a lot of
guys out there that are like falling in
love and already planning marriage and
already so [ __ ] obsessed with a girl
that they shouldn't even be with but
they're convincing themselves that
they're like oh you know we're so in
love and a girl is like either like I
didn't even know you liked me like that
or you know they're actually in a
relationship and she's not the right one
but she's the only one that'll keep his
yet so he's just so sprung on it yeah
it's [ __ ] ridiculous dude a lot of
people shouldn't be together but they
are you know there was this one girl
that I was with um I think I'd literally
I talked about it with Gobbo
when he was here but his Rose welcome
buff this [ __ ] shunned it did you uh
dog I think so the first time I met her
she was wearing a she lifts me up that'd
be [ __ ] funny
she uh she was I met her at Halloween
and she's joining there's not a nun
outfit and that's all it took
Wow I mean that's all that sometimes fix
for me now
si I want this [ __ ] that's the first
thing I thought be like something about
you I think your marriage material
yeah I want you and she was like the
most damaged human being I've ever been
with in my life
it makes it tough man dog first of all a
lot of pressure she was the she was like
when we first started dating she goes
she does you know you're the only Asian
person I've been with and she's a
Filipino girl when she goes the only
black guy is I was like well you're
gonna be surprised
let me let me show you let me show you
the size difference lady maybe six foot
one with a thickened don't match the
rest of it she was like I was the first
non black boyfriend Wow ever right solid
she had a black fetish or she just grew
up around that guy and I think she just
liked black dude oh that was like a [ __ ]
um so like she was a and when we were
going out I started to realize number
one like she had daddy issues
oh she had she grew up in a very cultish
type of religion it was you know like
it's it's it's it's like a form of
Christianity it's like a Filipino one
Iglesias
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one so there
I guess from what she was telling me and
you know if you are of this religion and
to defend you I don't like what the [ __ ]
can I tell you I don't know this is
based on my memory but they were like
there's like this whole thing of like
whoever donates more money has more
power in the church and type of [ __ ]
like that and so she know just most
religions yeah so she you know so she
had like this whole weird oh and also to
like if you're in that religion there
was another girl in my school that that
was also part of that religion a lot of
Filipino people are part of it but you
couldn't dance with somebody else and
you couldn't touch so when they was she
would go to prom and stuff I always
thought it was weird that she wouldn't
dance with anybody's because he was
against her religion she wasn't allowed
to dance with anybody what's up with
these religions
sucking the fun out of life though
[ __ ] no difficults love doing that
[ __ ] I let me take everything that's
joyful and [ __ ] make it not allowed
like make it illegal yeah she could have
danced she couldn't might have any type
of physical touch or shouldn't some [ __ ]
like that and so that's what she was a
part of but she and I went through some
[ __ ] drama because she was so damaged
that she the only way she equated
affection was through sex now you would
think that is wonderful as a young
person you would love that [ __ ] right
but she wanted to [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
oh she was too horny and I was doing
stand-up yeah I was I was working two
jobs and I was a full-time student
that's a lot of that's a lot of young
man work man Nathan that was too lazy I
could have I could have I would have
been like yeah let's [ __ ] all the time
which I did at that age I was too tired
yeah and so like for her she felt like
you know I didn't really she didn't feel
attractive because we weren't like
physically uh when we first started it
was like that too but then I would be
sacrificing you know slots doing
stand-up just hanging out with her I
didn't notice that about women that are
really good-looking is they're so used
to guys just [ __ ] watering them they
don't have to work they just they're
just constantly wanting to [ __ ] the crap
out of them so think so if you don't
give them that same attention like they
don't feel worthy anymore they don't
feel value yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's like you know it's just a
weird thing whatever has happened to her
when she was younger probably affected
how she views herself as a woman now I
think the woman I'm gonna marriage
probably be ugly as hell oh pretty smart
girl she's gonna be like super ugly dude
and then but just like a complete [ __ ]
genius like just amazingly brilliant you
don't want somebody to smart though man
I want someone Stephen Hawking smart
dude what whatever you buy two smarter
is like you you want somebody to at
least understand you a little bit
emotionally oh well I want them to be
emotionally intelligent that's hard to
have though it is right but like I don't
know man
try produce [ __ ] future Nobel Peace
Prize winners you know what I mean I
find out
a lot of hyper-intelligent people are
emotionally [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ]
emotionally [ __ ] because it's like I
think that's like God's balance so he'll
give you some [ __ ] but he'll take away a
lot of other stuff too you know yeah
that's true because I think I'm more
emotionally intelligent
yeah I'm just more of a hard worker
right oh yeah when it comes to like
being hyper intelligent I don't have the
brain capacity but I [ __ ] my brain shut
Soph I don't try to deal with that [ __ ]
yeah that's true I don't know I don't
even know what I want man I I'm not even
in that realm cuz you know I'm the
break-up still fresh for me yeah I was
in Vietnam and like it was g-word no Mad
Dog you met you met the [ __ ] the
Prince of [ __ ] Vietnam in case
[ __ ] cool man
yeah I did okay he built a club from
scratch on a rooftop I thought he was
just a be manager of a club no I told
you he was or I told you like if you
meet up with TK he's the Prince of
Vietnam that people say that's Danny
dough no but it's different yeah
TK's cool man and you know he he showed
me around he took care of me he got me a
little hook up with the Sheraton and and
not trying and [ __ ] and I stayed for
free and I said it was awesome dude yeah
and you know I feel like my value is
just higher over there
yeah because one light taller than
everybody else I'm actually average
height and taller yeah TK's at all
[ __ ] six-foot-something yeah
he's tell he's thought of me yeah but um
well I think there's a lot of things
working for me right it's the dating
scene is just different and and I think
that this this kind of the way that
people date in Asia is different from
the way that they date in America mm-hmm
this podcast is brought to you by a rake
on baby well check this out my friend
there's no need to get crazy this year
I'm letting you know ahead of time about
an amazing Black Friday Cyber Monday
deal on something you're actually going
to use every single day a pair of
wireless earbuds or head phones from Ray
Con I have been using ray con earbuds
for a minute now I walk daily and on my
daily walks I need some
music I need some podcasting I need some
genius brain podcasting and I hate wires
I don't want a wire dangling about my
face when I'm on these walks and when I
take it out and I put it in my pocket
it's not going to get tangled up so I
always use my rake on earbuds
specifically my rake on e25 so the sound
quality is great and the great thing
about rake on earbuds is that you get
high quality premium audio at about half
the price and they look really cool so
check out the best deal in premium audio
just got even better for Black Friday
and trust me you do not want to sleep on
this one go to buy rake on Comm slash
brain to check out Rea cons Black Friday
and Cyber Monday savings I can't even
tell you how good these deals will be
you will have to check them out on the
site that's by rake on.com slash brain
to get an amazing Black Friday deal on
ray cons by Ray con-com slash brain
western style of dating is like I think
it's it's first and foremost everyone's
looking for love
everyone's looking well aside from
[ __ ] around right if you're looking
for a committed relationship or you know
maybe you want good company or whatever
like the ultimate goal is romance love
and maybe like future commitments right
yeah but there's passion behind it sure
there's gold digging here and there but
even gold diggers don't want to MIT that
they're gold diggin they want to hide
that fact yeah in Asia girls are very
[ __ ] upfront well it's like I want
your money there how much do you make
[ __ ] like can I marry this guy like
it is a very and I and I realized like
this has been a constant thing for every
country that I've been to like Hong Kong
or China or like Vietnam or whatever
they're more bolder and more open when
it comes to what do you got for me
but not in that way you know they're
gauging like their future with you it's
very transactional it's very and I think
that love is a luxury of the rich like
only rich people have this freedom to
pursue you know romance and love in that
way it's
it's just expressed differently dude you
know what's so funny every time I hear
the story about an older age and couple
choosing love over what their family
wanted they always end up being poor
that's always like it's always like I
came from a rich noble family that I met
your father
yeah and I fell in love and now we're
dirt [ __ ] poor it's like well bad
choice mom what the [ __ ] and then they
look at each other and we don't love
each other anymore thank you as we
should have chose the money then [ __ ]
man
yeah there's always an element well
here's what I think it is - it's because
you're dealing with a developing country
mm-hmm and their dating world is
different from like a like a like a
country that's like like first of all
problems right like in our country women
have more I guess like freedom and being
able to work and earn a living for
themselves and and and and do all this
stuff and and we live fairly pretty well
compared to these other countries and so
like they have the freedom to like earn
on their own and they're like I want
something from a man that I can't get on
my own
I want affection I want all that like I
want company in that way but I can make
my own money so like there's more of an
independent strong woman kind of
mentality here right even though some
people are like yeah I want to
eventually get married but they still
don't do it for like how do I get out of
poverty or how do I get into this like
rich family like I feel like that is
very secondary women look for a partner
that they love and they want to be with
and then if he just so happens to be
rich what a win-win situation yeah you
know at least that's the facade or at
least that's the that's the narrative
that people want to believe in the
states right but out in Asia people are
boldly like nah dude like I want a rich
husband hmm I want a better life I want
this oh he's got a passport [ __ ] yeah I
want to be American take me to America
with you and it's um you know it's just
different I'm just like wow like this do
you feel like
that that kind of because met it's funny
because I think when people listen to
that they go oh that takes away what
marriage is actually supposed to be
about but actually that is originally
what marriage was for it is you're right
that was the actual reason it was a
binding contract and it was for wealth
purposes it yes it was it was to see
what you could offer somebody can take
away and build family wealth dude my
friend was gonna take me to a party like
the first weekend there I [ __ ] fell
asleep early and then he was like man
it's [ __ ] easy to get pretty company
out here and I'm like really like he's
like yeah man you just go up to you know
any of these girls you hit it off and
then you say hey man I'm gonna be going
to these freaking like resorts and
whatever if you want to come along with
me you know I mean you could do that
here but there's no weird stigma about
that [ __ ] right yeah yeah but um I mean
I'm sure it's out there too but what I
realize is they're more socially
liberated than Asian Americans here and
that blew my [ __ ] mind
because out there you could be like yes
I'm gonna do these trips you want a role
and then they'll be like [ __ ] yeah let's
[ __ ] roll and you party with them
[ __ ] whatever hang out and this nah um
don't get me wrong they do the same [ __ ]
here right but I don't think it's as
common and as frequent yeah
whereas out there they're like yeah okay
let's [ __ ] go let's let's roll it's
[ __ ] stay at these resorts it's
almost like you got groupies and [ __ ]
hmm and then there'll be your company
for like you know during that time so
you get it's it's almost like but out
here you gotta have money it's like the
status is different right so I know
there's a lot of rich dudes that are
mega rich that are bringing girls on
their yachts and they're legit all they
got to do is like yo man I'm gonna be
going to [ __ ] Miami you girls want to
come let's do it but the level of
stardom and money and game just has to
be way more yeah over over in Vietnam
you could be like Joe Schmo but it's
like you have some cash it's like your
let's go party and then let's [ __ ]
let's go yeah well there we're not Joe
schmo's I think that's the difference
right so out there like I think my value
as a human being just became higher
because
the passport thing Oh like I'm hanging
out with celebrities or whatever but at
the same time I saw guys do this like
after I didn't believe it at first and
then later like we would meet um you
know like either expats like or
Vietnamese Americans or Vietnamese
Australians or whatever guys that are
just hanging out there and then I'd
witnessed this firsthand
they'll just meet a girl they'll be like
that it up BAM there with them dude I
had this one this yeah it is just
[ __ ] crazy man like um [ __ ] it never
mind I'm not gonna open that story up
cuz he might be listening that's [ __ ]
crazy man yeah but it's it to me I
didn't I didn't realize how easy it was
and then he was like you should open up
to tinder that's how I met my girl I'm
like are you serious gonna find some
wholesome girls and his girl was really
wholesome she's really [ __ ] cool
she's not a hook or anything like that
you know but my impression of tinder is
like you know it's a hook-up thing you
hook up no one's there for serious game
or whatever it's all hoes or whatever I
don't know I never caught on so I had a
stupid-ass idea about it he goes you
just [ __ ] try it and I'm I open it
and I try it and I get crazy hits like
he's like [ __ ] dude that's a lot like
and then all he's gonna wanna [ __ ]
talk to me and then it was kind of cool
because it's like all girls don't you
don't even know my they're not groupies
they don't know anything about JK they
don't know anything about what I've done
they just want to get to know me so they
might be find me attractive that's
[ __ ] dope but as I'm talking to them
one by one I'm like you're [ __ ] cute
but you have no substance you're [ __ ]
cute but like I mean yeah you don't
really need substance to chill but I
don't want them to come on vacation with
me yeah or like some of them their
English isn't that good and immediately
when they asked for my Instagram right
they'll go oh wow you're famous give me
a shoutout
oh wow you're famous can you teach me
how to be famous oh wow like they
immediately just [ __ ] go in for the
kill they ask boldly for [ __ ] like that
are you rich in America are you this in
that like it's it
it's it kills the fun for me because it
feels like they're hoes and I'm a pimp
or like i'ma I'm a guy that's up my
trick I'm like paying for them yeah
and it's like they're gaming me like a
gold digger like I I felt really weird
about it and um I mean it all depends on
what kind of guy you are right like me I
like intellectual like back and forth I
like flirting
I like the chase I like a lot of things
that kind of build it up yeah I mean
you're also at a different place in your
life now because if that's the case of
what we want if I just wanted somebody
to just [ __ ] around with just because
whatever they get some type of high of
being off z-list youtuber you know
number one I'm already I'm already
questioning your credibility as a person
I'm also just it's like me yeah me
awesome you should really shoot for the
stars [ __ ] this that's the big that
you're gonna suck
come on yeah like you're aiming low girl
exactly like I'm already judging you at
that point right so far for what we find
attractive now too especially for me
like I like women who are strong
independent and can do that a hand on
the world yeah doesn't mean that I won't
do nice things for the person that I'm
with yeah and if I wanted a transaction
I'd get a hooker
exactly they'll be way cleaner yeah but
I don't want that you know I mean like
I'm gonna talk to you I want to engage
yeah
so because of that like I actually man
it was difficult dude like there or it
was the first time or I'm like wow like
I never had genuine girls that don't
know who the [ __ ] I am one after the
other whether it's the club tinder all
these things find me interesting like
there was one that was just like I'm at
the bar she just comes straight up to me
[ __ ] hugs me up well I'm like what
the [ __ ] this is crazy right just
flirting with me and [ __ ] and I'm just
like but it's weird I think you're
trying to take something from me yeah
and it's not because you're you want to
get to know me yeah
was it is it is it hard to I find it
hard to find somebody attractive not
just because the accent but because I
can't communicate with them well so
that's a big thing so like I'll be
obviously like physically attracted
there'll be girls that are just like
you're drop-dead gorgeous what the [ __ ]
right yeah and this is one time I'm
talking to this girl and we're on Google
[ __ ] translate back and forth it was
kind of cute at first yeah and then
after a while I was just like it's
exhausting I can't do this man I can't
keep going back [ __ ] yeah and then
yeah I mean it's cute and I'm like
alright girl I got to move on like
there's no there's no chemistry here
he's dies yeah and I and my friends like
just [ __ ] touch her man like why are
you being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like
bro I am past that stage I've touched a
lot of women yeah you know like I I mean
I'm not even to [ __ ] brag it's like
there's a point where I'm [ __ ] 35 I
need more it's like been there done that
type of [ __ ] yeah I mean I'm 30 I mean I
need more to feel like there's a
stronger connection and energy or it's
entertaining at least yeah like I'm not
trying to be in love I don't I don't
know if people understand what I'm
saying because if I heard this when I
was in my 20s I wouldn't understand I
said what the [ __ ] are you talking about
dude the [ __ ] touched you let's go [ __ ]
yeah but the thing is you once you
achieve a certain level of connection
with someone then um you just can't go
back to empty connections cuz it's it's
not good enough look I said you're value
changing what you find attractive -
right also - I can't move passive
enemies accent dude I've been doing that
asked for life that [ __ ] would [ __ ] Mia
you want to go to my bed it is exactly
kind of cute dude okay so here's a lot
of [ __ ] crazy things about the
Vietnamese culture from what I observed
at the short time that I was in right so
like I thought they were gonna be
conservative oh I thought they were
gonna be more strict and all that
because most of my Vietnamese American
friends are different generation though
that was like you know I mean that when
they came to this data then and what
they went through then now completely
different yeah and and when I went over
there dude like two out of 10 people had
tattoos a lot of people were tatted up
like and it's very common in the culture
moms kids whatever like people are
tatted the [ __ ] up right and they work
regular jobs with it it's not like a bad
like stigma but the
I'm pretty sure the vietnamese-american
community it's still a stigma yeah had
it up all the time and everywhere and
it's also because a lot of them came
through well obviously they're refugees
is that yeah but you know a lot of they
are the cathodic religion [ __ ] adhere
to them are true you know yeah yeah
that's true so that that probably
culturally is just too different yeah
oops now you know and another thing that
shocked me was how Western and
provocative the girls might have dressed
and like and no one's batting an eye and
I'm just like watched all [ __ ] these
girls man I love it like booty shorts
and all yeah very Western you know like
just like la girls and [ __ ] and I wasn't
expecting that
I really wasn't I was expecting a more
reserved and like not socially liberal
like yeah and sexually liberated culture
I was like what the [ __ ] like this is
blowing my mind that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah makes me want to be single and go
there and see what happens it's an
interesting experience man and and I
think also like I'll be married oh I'm
just kidding just not eat not only the
dating scene is so foreign I think it's
one of those places where the only thing
Western or American about it is the
clothing maybe this podcast is brought
to you by away Beibei away luck is
thoughtful luggage for modern travelers
away luggage is the luggage of my choice
and I say this with the utmost
confidence it is actually my favorite
luggage to carry on when I travel I
travel about I say about thirty percent
out of every month every year because
I'm a traveling boy majority the time
I'm gonna use a bigger carry-on and the
away travel bigger carry-on is the one
that I use all the time the compression
straps are great the wheels are amazing
it's super durable even though it feels
like a soft plastic it's so so durable I
have mine in all black it's sleek it's
modern and looks great and it it could
hold a lot of pigs and you'd be
surprised about the design of the weight
luggage and how well it
compartmentalizes the things that you
need
it came with laundry bag in it and
there's just a bunch of cool things that
it comes with
well that a lot of luggages that I've
had didn't really come with like for
example let me just list a few things
for you guys alright there's an optional
ejectable battery to keep your phone
charged which is really important for me
a removable laundry bag to separate
dirty clothes from clean clothes frickin
cool
there's look do you just--just--just get
the luggage man like it's it's it's one
of my favorite things to have and you'd
be surprised to also with when you get
luggage and you buy ones that aren't
really good you'll see how long it lasts
I've been using the away luggage for a
while now and it works just as good as
the first day that I got it and I and I
beat it up pretty bad so that's my
personal anecdote and my personal usage
from it so I love it
if you guys want to get the bigger
carry-on I think it's a good move for
people who do travel every now and then
so check it out for $20 off a suitcase
visit away travel comm slash genius
brain and use promo code genius brain
during checkout my friends so one more
time for $20 off a suitcase visit away
travel.com slash genius brain and use
promo code genius brain during checkout
and you get a true experience of like so
America has so much of an influence all
over the [ __ ] world
right so no matter what we're exporting
culture no matter what part of the world
you're at Vietnam less than 1% of that
country is tourism is Americans well so
when you go there nothing's catered to
me yeah I really felt like oh [ __ ]
like it's like I'm in a foreign country
it's like it's a communist Wonderland
bro
yeah it's like opposite world for ya you
know like [ __ ] ton of Russians and
Chinese and like former communist
countries and like that's their vacation
spot yeah and I mean to us French and
Europeans but like there are no I don't
hear any Americans when I heard them I
just try to have a conversation with
them I started to miss English you know
and I'm just like wow dude this is like
crazy like I that's how I realized
America Americans can be so like
entitled and American centric because no
matter where we go in the world
um there's a piece of us yeah you know
because of how domineering our presence
is all over the world yeah and people
understand us because of the because of
our Hollywood and and you export
American culture so much and they're
watching our news so it's almost like
they cater to us unintentionally Yeah
right and then so when we go there we
almost expect a fact that everybody
should kind of know English and all that
and then this is the first time where
I'm just like oh [ __ ] damn do we we do
run the world but not here man
yeah this is one place where like we're
really don't we don't have a any power
yeah that's that's the the hard part for
a lot of I think Americans when they
when they go travel and it's the stuff
that we always see on Twitter it's like
the stuff that becomes really
problematic is we're so used to being
top dog that we go when we go into a
country where we're not we get offended
that they don't know that we're top dogs
oh yeah you know I mean it's like well
why don't you know this what it's like
when they when they speak English and
they don't understand they get
frustrated yeah well imagine how
frustrating it is for them that you go
to their country and you don't can't
speak the language is the other way
around
you should be frustrated at your lack of
ability to speak the language of the
country yeah but that's just kind of
like how we're bred here it's like
America's number one everybody should
know English American English too
yeah I was on this um it was so funny to
like it's American English is so
different from like British English to
like the things that they say I was I
was shooting the show I can't say what
it's about yet but one of the cast
members is uh British and she would just
say [ __ ] I'm like that's not English I
don't know what the [ __ ] you're saying
dude because they could understand us
but we can't understand them do shusei
so she would say stuff like well you
know when they're so you have all these
things ready for you especially out
there in the Lada and I'm like the Lada
I was like the larder what's the larder
she was like oh the pantry I'm like what
the [ __ ] you know there's so there's
words that I just never heard of before
it like the Lada the Lauda is the pantry
and I found out the reason why
a lot of American people can't do a
British accent like I my [ __ ] was poppin
when I was on set but this is caught
copy it yeah but now I haven't heard it
in like three or four days I completely
lost it like the British English accent
the original English accent depending on
where you're from she has like that
classic one that we always imitate they
round their words in the front and
pronounce all their continents and they
open their mouths so for us when we
speak we kind of muddle our words yeah
like British is like we all hello hello
hello it's all her so she was saying
they're teaching me how to do a British
allows when you see she goes I want you
to say this what are you going to have
for lunch today
so even saying that hot yeah what are
you are you going to have for lunch
today there throaty it's very thought
it's in the front of the mouth all and
when I wasn't throwing it from the top
yeah so it's really rounded and then the
e's are really sharp and they say all
their consonants and i was trying to
speak like that all day my [ __ ] jaw
got tired it's exhausting damn what are
you going to have the lunch today is
that why their teeth all [ __ ] up
problem it was interesting like I was
talking to somebody else - that was
there wasn't a cast member it was
somebody else but this person was from
the UK and they were talking about kind
of like just how different it wasn't
this person was a normal person but
we're talking about just how different
things are here versus there right yeah
especially specifically food like our
food and the amount of produce that we
have more in California I think we take
that for granted because of how
accessible it is yes right because I dog
I saw this one thing that they were
eating and you know British food I think
has come a long way like in terms of
like innovation and what it tastes like
but if you saw the [ __ ] that it came
from dog that [ __ ] is now like my thing
is like you're all these British white
people you guys stole all these spices
and you chose not to use any of them
like what the [ __ ] was that about
how you gonna [ __ ] pillage India and
then come back with all the [ __ ] and
never use any of your spices you know
potatoes not even native to them Oh
potatoes aren't native no so potato is
from the New World
so it was the language - for Columbus
and all and everybody that started to
come in and then they got potato from
natives and then they brought it back so
before that you know they only had like
wheat and breads really yes and their
tables like a huge [ __ ] stable out
there the potato is like half their diet
you know it to me it's kind of
remarkable how the Europeans in the cold
survived yeah because the thing is like
the more harsh your climate like you
know like the Inuit or whatever it's
hard to get food it's hard as [ __ ]
that's why their food is so bland and
and you what the hell can you grow out
there you can't grow [ __ ] and then your
winters are so damn long you've got to
figure out how to preserve and all that
so if you think about Europe as a whole
right like there's not well spices and
all that [ __ ] doesn't grow because all
that [ __ ] comes from Southeast Asia
mm-hmm and the only thing they can do is
cure their meets salt [ __ ] and they only
got proteins and maybe you know bread
yeah and that's literally all their food
doc I saw this [ __ ] have you heard of
this [ __ ] called jellied eel you mean
that canned it's so it's like your thing
that they it's like lutefisk right but
it's it's it's just it's eel that's been
gelatinize with this with the with
whatever the collagen that was with is
within the eel yeah and it's like this
old English food that they eat and it's
jelly it looks [ __ ] disgusting and so
I asked this person I was like so have
you had jelly do she goes it's
absolutely delicious and I'm like [ __ ]
you have lost your [ __ ] mind
what you mean is delicious and mind you
I love this person like this woman I
could be around for the rest of my life
and I love her but when she said jelly
eel is delicious and I said I've seen it
before and it's just it looks bland oh
right so if you guys go on YouTube
you'll see this video of this space of
the spot that's like really well known
for this mince pie mm-hmm and they put
like this parsley sauce over it and they
serve jellied eel now it sounds a lot
better the way I'm explaining it but if
you see this video and you look it up it
looks like trash
and this man sitting that he goes was
like 'my father was the first person
that ever you know serve all this stuff
and you know they really really liked it
and I was like first of all dude that
[ __ ] looks like depression food and they
still serve it the same way his dad made
it like 60 years ago and it looks like
barf and these [ __ ] before they
closed that pie up with the pastry they
[ __ ] just dumped a bunch of hos water
on it and they clean it up and they use
for the steam I was like [ __ ] you
season your food with water is that why
your food tastes so bland I'm like damn
dude like British food back in the day
sucked with the steam they said that and
like it's so before they bake it they
make this weird little minced meat with
it and put it into this pie tin oh and
they put dumped a bunch of [ __ ] hose
water in it and they close up do they
just add salt is that all I guess and I
guess I'd they're like yeah we put water
in it so it steams and it cooks but I'm
like it looks like you just seasoned it
with water dude [ __ ] white people do
use some salt use some [ __ ] salt in
your food goddamn it so when you had
traditional what is it British food or
whatever like was it way more bland and
was it more mild and like what was it I
mean I don't know like when I when I
when I had that food I mean it's hard to
say right so this like casserole mince
pies and stuff which I don't know how
like typical this is too like UK food
but you know it's like meat and potatoes
man and it's it's so bland like that's
all they eat out there yes well I do
feel like the rest of the world doesn't
have like strong flavour like America
weather I mean like even American white
people food right that's very fatty very
salty every time I go all over the world
it's never as intense as it is out here
our portions are ridiculous shirt our
portions are huge like it's super salty
or super fatty or whatever and all over
Asia even in and I guess like in Europe
I've only been to France so I wouldn't
know the other stuff but they say French
food is fattier but I don't think it's
as intense as American food well it's
because it's fattier but the portions
are right you know because yeah I
understand what they mean fattier
because there's a lot of butter in there
[ __ ] it's very decadent but they're also
not giving you a [ __ ] 4 pound plate
of whatever they're served
I see so I was watching this other
podcast for the who but he's from like
New Zealand and he was talking about how
in New Zealand he comes over here he
goes I have a fast metabolism but if I
didn't I'd be [ __ ] yeah that's because
the portions are ridiculous he goes I
forget that when you orders to order
things here just expect to be gargantuan
because he's not used to that [ __ ] that
she was talking about nachos he was like
your nachos are ridiculous yeah he goes
there
they're made for one person but they
should feed like two or three that's
true that's true yeah it's crazy because
when I was out in Vietnam you know the
portions are much smaller but I saw
those little [ __ ] baby ass [ __ ]
stools you were sitting like how the
[ __ ] did you sit on that dude I would
destroy those things dude you're gonna
have a blast doing it's all the baby
chairs like they sell those for babies
here they're kindergarden chairs you're
gonna be a lot of the restaurants are
like that day when I travel to Vietnam
I'm going to bring my own chair like one
of those small portable ones I have to
be like so large I have one that's tied
to a backpack nice time to just open it
and then it turns the best because I saw
that [ __ ] I know for a fact I'm breaking
and I would feel terrible if I broke it
a little chair so I have to bring like
my own chair and carry it around you're
gonna have a [ __ ] blast dude I have
it so for 12 days I didn't eat the same
meal twice there's so much food over
there dude that's the variety like
that's what I love about ages there's so
much variety
right like sure it might be similar like
noodle soup but the variety is just
endless yeah and I still left not eating
everything that I wanted to
it's just depends on what region you go
to to like yeah if enemies was very very
if you go to UM just even like the
Vietnamese food that we have in the SUV
if you go to the OC way different yeah
there's more variety because the OC is
very representative of Vietnamese
cuisine because in every spot and like
the OC is different some spots some
spots would be like not John what they
have like the seafood and [ __ ] the other
spot it's not so it's like more pork
base and the that's why I love the Oh
Sees Vietnamese food it's so [ __ ]
good dude and I was mind blown because
in Vietnam I think it's better yeah oh
and that's just kind of crazy cuz I
don't know man there's something about
it
I feel like the Asian tastebuds to the
way that they run food out even in Japan
and everywhere it's a little more toned
down than out here so same thing with
like everything saltier here
everything's more whatever they're you
know like out there it's not yeah so
yeah I ended up like losing a pound or
two but then I felt better
yeah and yeah I mean man I want to go
back so if you go back I'm gonna go back
I'll meet you there
Vietnam is one of those spots to like
I've always wanted like I grew up with
the [ __ ] that I've been amis people my
whole life that's why you know and you
mean you know I knew a bunch of it amis
[ __ ] yes literally all the girls I date
or Vietnamese it's my top 5 favorite
foods like hands-down Vietnamese food is
[ __ ] amazing
like I mean even Amy's food if not two
times a week or at least once yeah I
have to something I grew up with it's
like comfort food to me yeah you know at
first when it first started off eating
Vietnamese but I was only eating like
[ __ ] and then then I started you know
spanning out into like hoodoos and then
[ __ ] Boonton real but you know I had
all that [ __ ] yeah you're all you had
like bun say I had it with snail Bo real
with snail that sounds [ __ ] no like a
venom is food is so varied like muriel
used to hate nummies food really cuz she
only had korean fuh that [ __ ] Oh
disgusting [ __ ] they don't even boil
like bones in that I say [ __ ] whack
man water and msg Korean fuzz [ __ ]
whack and so that's what that was her
perception of Vietnamese food but then
she had [ __ ] like like like bun sale
oh man can like she hit all this other
[ __ ] she didn't really like bun mail and
she [ __ ] loved it she goes this is
Vietnamese food I was like yeah man like
you've only had fun and fuzz delicious
if you have a good bowl of pho yeah but
if you're not like expanding out then
you're missing out on this whole [ __ ]
flavor spectrum dude the French is
influence on Vietnamese food is uh no
y'all dude like even even a bun meat bun
me is a [ __ ] French baguette with pate
and sighing make it so fresh yeah so
fresh break baked bread everything
everyday it's in the ingredients that
they use so good because it's like
farm-to-table yeah but if you've never
been to a developing country notable do
they [ __ ] slaughter this chicken
it's that yeah you go to the [ __ ]
market and they have a butcher shop yeah
meat all open yeah under the Sun flies
all over that [ __ ] there you're
gonna see some shade where you're like
this might give me a stomachache cuz
your diary out there I think I have what
I call third-world intestines okay I'm
okay
well cuz right so like you know like
there's the gut biome right and I think
like when you get introduced to a
certain bacteria of that region I've
been to Southeast Asia like four or five
times now or something
you find after that yeah I probably had
diarrhea when I went to Thailand and all
this stuff before but you're just body
memorizes it
I had bloating the first day diarrhea
like for like one [ __ ] after that smooth
sailing and people were like don't drink
the ice you gotta drink bottled water
every single time don't drink tab don't
do this don't do that and I'm all like
[ __ ] it bro
[ __ ] [ __ ] if I died I don't give a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] lost your mind I would never
do that [ __ ] dude you know what I saw my
friend do it and I'm like man you've
been here for 15 years you survived
yeah if he was scared because I mean
like people in Tijuana right they'll say
don't drink the [ __ ] tap and the
locals won't drink the tap yeah that's a
that's a that's a sure sign yeah when I
see the locals do it I'm like well [ __ ]
I just need the bacteria that's [ __ ]
but I had two friends who went to the
who were pretty much almost going to the
hospital cuz the ice that they drank or
whatever and I'm like you just got weak
stomachs that's why I think you just
built as a different human being yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy dude there's no I'm
going to Vietnam and be like everybody
said hey only drink bottle water you
like mean [ __ ] you [ __ ] it's not
drinking you [ __ ] maniac yeah but
also it's like my friends that are like
expat Americans they go to these [ __ ]
restaurants they're fine you know like
they said that they they don't even eat
at places if if a friend doesn't
introduce them so they don't do this
thing where you're like mmm that place
yeah because they're like you don't know
the rapport you don't know they're using
mystery meat like some of them they're
just like trying to make ends
and they're just gonna do things you
know but like there's word of mouth
right and people like that place is good
you know I know that family like that's
how people start I guess like finding
places out there yeah so if you see man
I [ __ ] ate Boone real a [ __ ]
noodle soup at a tire shop dude oh and
that place was so grimy it's literally a
[ __ ] mechanic shop so imagine a place
by day they do tire work on scooters and
at night it's a it's a noodle restaurant
they just lay out big [ __ ] what do you
call those those those big pots yeah
they got the stock go and they just
[ __ ] set that [ __ ] up and they set up
tables and chairs people do that [ __ ]
it's literally their house and if one of
their houses the restaurant yeah it's
that's literally what it is yeah
and I had [ __ ] I had a roach crawl up my
leg I'm just eating food I'm just
kicking that [ __ ] off I don't give a
[ __ ] there's flies whatever man but that
kind of [ __ ] will turn a lot of people
off I think that's the type of [ __ ] I
want to go to them cuz I like that [ __ ]
because it makes me feel like I'm out of
my element yeah that's what it the food
so [ __ ] good you're not focusing on
the roach on your [ __ ] toe that's
[ __ ] funny yes 100% agree oh you're
gonna have a bunch of vlogs dude I got
yeah I got a lot dude you're there for
two [ __ ] weeks man oh yeah I got
about 11 days worth of vlogs so [ __ ] I
can't wait to get them out [ __ ] crazy
man to [ __ ] you're just living it up
do this feel single and just going about
traveling the [ __ ] world they're not
for five years okay I've been running a
[ __ ] company giving my life to them
first so I cut out my white anchor just
for this yep it's [ __ ] been the best
it's interesting though I think like
some people when they take their
breakups like some people take it very
poorly but some people take it in stride
like some people we know yeah home and
[ __ ] cry like a little [ __ ] all day
it's like I think for you like you've
been you've always been able to like car
compartmentalize your feelings at what's
going on it's like okay and and it's not
like for you when you when you broke up
with her it happened overnight that was
a process that was a step to
and then we lived together for like
almost two months after the breakup
and and we cried together we were there
for each other we were able to like ease
out of the pain you know yeah and I
think I was just ready to [ __ ] be in
charge of just myself I think you've
been ready for a while man I think like
even though for you you can you you have
this ability to to cut out [ __ ]
really well but you do have a really big
heart so it's still very hard if there's
like a man there's this there's this
want of you know what you want to do but
it's you're also somebody else who just
you're not gonna watch somebody drown in
front of you and not help them out
that's that's just not in your [ __ ]
blood you know I think to a certain
extent it just became really detrimental
to you yeah because you were giving up
so much of yourself and not checking up
on yourself that you thought that okay
well I got all these people on my back
like not in that type of way but that
you're carrying their weight yeah and if
you left them out you feel like a
[ __ ] like a Chauncy ass [ __ ]
you know yeah that's the thing man is I
don't like to I don't like to give up on
people that I care about Yeah right and
I felt that you know leaving or breaking
up or whatever I thought that was
failing on on the relationship in us
yeah but I'm super thankful that she
brought it up and she realized it and
she saw that it was inevitable like it
was just a downward spiral because I
think the my just my personality is I
don't give up when I just go I just go
until it works yeah and sometimes that's
a stupid way to approach life yeah
because you don't you don't have an
endgame you don't know when when to say
okay this isn't working like I don't
like to admit to it because to me that's
failure I just want to keep fighting
until it wins and then after that I was
like that's exactly when my buddy from
Vietnam Danny though he was like hey man
like I went through a similar situation
and he's like come to Vietnam I mean
like I've been trying to get you to come
here in the last ten years I made a life
for myself that he's like I have no
friends out here please somebody speak
English to me it's he was one of the
original members of JK and he helped us
like build a film oh that's like he's
the one who didn't yes right man so it
was like a such a good story because man
there's so much more we can talk about
but
like it's like he had to do what he had
to do and I think he's still [ __ ]
guilty about this cuz the for the first
four days I was there he would not shut
the [ __ ] up about it and I was like
Danny I accept your decision it's been
15 [ __ ] years bro like like move on
and he's like nah bro you don't
understand I feel bad so basically he
was apologizing for the first four
[ __ ] days that he abandoned us so we
did pretty well first he just kept
making reasons why he had to move to
Vietnam and and almost like Danny like I
think you're hurt more than I am yeah
cuz he's like yeah he's like at the time
you know like I felt like I was leaving
you guys and I'm not I'm not like that
like I just you know I just like I just
had dreams being a director I'm like we
accept it yeah we moved on you know like
in and so then I realized that I just
got to let him talk and every day he
would bring you said I get rid of that
guilt he had so much guilt and that's
when I realized that this is a really
true friend that I did not appreciate
yeah cuz I didn't realize how much it
hurt him that he had to leave JK and
create a life for himself and he's doing
really [ __ ] well out there yeah did a
feature film he's doing another one this
April and he's working with this huge
pop star out there named like Sun ton or
some [ __ ] like that I forgot his name
but he yea dude like he's doing great
and I'm just like hella proud of him but
the the amount of guilt that he was
carrying and he's like I just wanted you
guys you and Bart to come to Vietnam and
us and you see like what it was all
worth it that I left
JK to do this and I'm like man it
doesn't even matter do this like hey
Danny is like I haven't thought about
you once that's it you left I was like I
only thought about you now that you hit
me up other than that I little if you
died I would have never known but he was
in it he was in a toxic relationship too
and then well his ended up pretty bad in
a way we're like he got cheated on and
all that stuff and I was like yeah
that's rough man but he's like you she's
like I know that I know the right thing
that you need and then he brought me out
and he man this guy he set everything up
for me I didn't have to [ __ ] think
that his apology tour dude
dude he [ __ ] I literally walked in he
was
or guide he was my he setup all the
meals everything like he thought of
everything ahead and I'm so [ __ ]
thankful because that was the first time
when I was able to just take a ride in
someone's back seat
cuz I'm always in control yeah for
something you know like whenever I'm
vacationing or whatever it's like
someone's looking at me hey what are we
gonna do next what are gonna do that can
you choose what the food or whatever
you're like what do you think what do
you think people have to look at me and
and I have to make a decision and I
didn't realize like I wanted to be taken
care of from time to time that's what a
vacation was vacation was just always us
trying to plant [ __ ] out you know yeah
[ __ ] man I didn't want to do that
sometimes I just want it like I've been
on set for two weeks
I've been on set for two weeks right
when I got back I just started unpacking
on cleaning setting up this office so
it's like [ __ ] we can't get a break
right yeah I couldn't you know I can't
yeah cuz you know Thanksgiving is
starting so we got a rack up these
[ __ ] podcasts and you know which
which I like doing the podcast is just
more along the lines of like [ __ ] I got
so much [ __ ] to get done I can't even
believe it for sure and I haven't really
thought about like the time to really
develop what we have to do in terms of
like a personal life yeah and that [ __ ]
has always been pushed to the wayside
and I think it's well here's the thing
to like I do understand there's a
give-and-take cuz when I don't work I
don't make money and so when I chose not
to work it was one that was the most
broke yeah and now that I've been
working a lot more being more proactive
like you know money is getting better
now
now I'm not now I'm not sweating my ass
off yeah cuz before I was it makes you
relax yeah it's like it's like it's like
which stress do I want the poor people
stress or do I want like not of time man
you know because poor people stress was
rough but when you take a little break I
feel like it's it's kind of like uh it
makes me feel grateful about what I have
back home okay take a break and I'm like
this is awesome he goes wait it's all
thanks to all the work that I put in
that I can enjoy this it's all thanks to
the people that are listening it's all
thanks to all this [ __ ] when you're in
the [ __ ] mix man you just like it's
hard to see that right but when you're
when you're outside looking in you're
just like oh I can't wait to get back
and [ __ ] come up with more [ __ ] and
then like yeah I think it's it's hella
important kind of like you can't just
keep working out working out you got a
view out of sleep you gotta rest you
gotta take your breaks
well I always talk about this and I
think this has been like a really good
perspective that I've been taking on a
lot of things and when we were working
on set and there was this girl that I
met there and what I really liked about
her too was like she's a very successful
actress right but her route to her
success was very long and arduous and
she was childhood act or whatever mm-hmm
I think she's didn't pan out for him the
way that she didn't so she finally she
finally popped off at like 36 35 right
but people don't know she's been acting
she was 9 [ __ ] years old Wow
you know and so for her like I remember
when we were we were shooting this and
oh she's already on like a couple of
very successful shows like she's [ __ ]
really successful now but and when we
were wrapping this up she started
tearing up like she was sad that we were
wrapping up the show because the food
was so good no let me know even get me
started on the food but like she was sad
and also are you crying you know and she
kind of said she's just like you know
I've been doing this thing for a long
time and she goes like she's very she'll
I'm just grateful that I get to do this
she was I know
people who were actors and actresses
that they had been putting in the work
just as long as I have and they still
haven't caught that break yeah but I
caught my break and now I'm doing a
second and a third show and now it's all
about perspective you know for her so
she even though that she's been through
this process before of shooting a pilot
it still makes her very emotional that
she could look around and say like damn
I'm getting paid to do this like before
I was doing the same thing and not
getting paid yeah hoping that I get a
[ __ ] break and it finally happened
and it keeps happening for me over and
over now because now my foots in the
[ __ ] door yeah and that that
perspective of being grateful even
though you're getting to do what you do
if you take a step back and like [ __ ]
what else could I be doing right now
yeah like I don't I don't I complain
about small [ __ ] but I never complain
about the position that I'm in because I
wouldn't be here if I didn't have these
opportunities you know and I think that
was so cool to see like when I look at
her I'm like I'm trying to be where
you're at
yeah but for her but even for her she
feels even more gratitude than I did and
that's a good person to kind of take the
lead from because what I noticed is it's
so important to be around people that
you want to share that energy with
because I
man you know like I was very unemotional
so I didn't really pay attention to how
the people around me can affect me cuz
you know in my head I'm like well [ __ ]
everybody I think for myself but I'm
unaware of their influence that they
have around me oh yeah so I'm like I
want to surround myself around people
who are like either more grateful than I
am or if I notice someone that is being
ungrateful I I limit the amount of time
that I spend with him and I limit the
amount of time of trying to work on them
to get grateful yeah
I think I spent way too much [ __ ]
time trying to fix other people yeah me
it's like alright [ __ ] that dude
I just got to work and figure out who
are the people that I want to spend more
time with and who are the people that
are like really grateful and everyone
else like I'll be there for them but
they got a [ __ ] get to my level I'm
not gonna boost them up anymore yeah I
think there's there's this there's a
point that that we have to find is like
how much can I be quote unquote a good
friend by definition in terms of me
trying to be there for somebody yeah to
the point where the other side is like
how much can you take from me before I
snap yeah because when I think like
that's what happens to a lot of like I
think cuz you and I also both grew up in
a religious family yeah I think putting
people putting other people's needs
before ours is just natural for us yeah
cuz it's kind of sinful to be selfish
exactly exactly so for us when we when
we do that it does make us feel good
that we could help these people that's
the trade-off that we get but there's
this point of no return or you're just
like oh [ __ ] now I'm being drained every
[ __ ] you become a pastor yeah and
that's what happens yeah oh [ __ ] you
know I always tell my really close
friends it's like you'll always hit me
up when you need something I'll be there
and if I get exhausted I'll like I don't
know but um let me find that medium for
myself you don't have to worry about
that because I want us to be good
friends yeah if I say like hey I can't
help you out on that right now it's
because I'm emotionally exhausting that
wouldn't be any help for hope for you
because I can't I can't respond even
take your frustration out on them
exactly I don't want to [ __ ] do that
it won't be like you know it is a
perfect opportunity to tell you shut up
you [ __ ] stupid yeah I don't want to
be the shut the [ __ ] up your problems
aren't nothing type of friend yeah you
know so if I'm if I'm
though in most cases it's it's nothing
yeah we do have a lot of problems that
are absolutely [ __ ] nothing and most
of the time we just need somebody to
listen yeah but I got to be mentally
prepared to listen because if I'm not at
that point then you're just gonna get
[ __ ] from me and I don't want to be that
friend so it's like you know we have to
really find and balance that out and I
think for us this year we're finding
that you know we're giving a lot now and
for us we need that time to just kind of
do our own thing and you know enjoy what
we're doing like I think this podcast
was a really good move for us because
it's it's it's our own thing yes it's
fun too you know and we're watching this
grow yep constantly and it's it's it's
it's been a really good blessing too cuz
I've always been doing the short format
stuff without being able to fully
explain myself and that has been the the
weird thing it's like oh yo people
people like long content they do and I'm
glad that people actually like long
khanh didn't know because before it was
like how do I get a three-minute video
out until until my perspective on this
it's too limiting man yeah yeah it's and
you I think the whole point is like you
got to do what your personality is best
at doing and you can thrive in that and
you can express yourself the best way
possible because for some people that
three-minute mark might be really good
for them or like you know we got the
vine kids and whatever like the
Instagram story kids right like they're
they're really [ __ ] good at that yeah
so people just gotta like get in where
they fit in and I like I like this -
like I like talking for long-ass periods
and just going off on crazy rants and
[ __ ] like that so I mean think that's
like our I think I think that's why the
podcast [ __ ] works really well first yes
but for men I was like [ __ ] man I can't
really explain myself like I need to say
my [ __ ] [ __ ] well you know they actually
wraps this episode up speaking of
talking [ __ ] along but anyways guys
yeah that's this episode of the genius
brain podcast thank you very much
remember every Thursday and Sundays were
up if you guys wants to talk about
certain topics leave it in the comments
below
oh yeah and then you catch us on iTunes
Spotify stitcher remember this podcast
we just talked about anything and
everything we don't really have like
direct topics really depends on what we
think about the time but we're just here
to be with you on your commuting your
everyday lives
thank you guys for listening and we'll
see y'all next time good bye shirt